My guests on under the skin today is Dr.
Jordan Peterson.
Clinical psychology is professor of
psychology at the University of Toronto
and author of books including maps of
meaning,
the architecture of belief.
And He's recent bestseller 12 rules for
life.
First garnering mainstream media
attention in 2016 when he objected to
compelled speech legislation in Canada.
He has steadily been making a name for
himself as a voice of the anti political
correctness movement and has cultivated
a slew of predominantly young male
followers,
touted by some as an academic rockstar.
And the most important thinker in the
west and by others as a provocateur.
And firebrand of the alt right is also
part of a new Internet savvy group of
controversial thinkers that have been
deemed the intellectual dark web Jordan
Peterson.
And thank you for coming on under the
skin.
Thanks very much for the invitation.
I,
I'm excited to speak to you because my
interest in your work was either prior
to or somehow abstract from the
controversies that have brought you to
mainstream attention.
And I said,
I was thinking then as a clinical
psychologist,
I was wondering about the how,
uh,
interwoven the relationship between
psychology and,
and mythology and archetypes is,
well,
one of the things that happened I think
was the,
when the political scandal broke around
me in Canada,
which was in September,
2016 people came to check me out because
of the scandal,
but they stayed because of the
psychology.
By that time I already had about 300
hours of youtube lectures,
which probably saved me in some sense
because when I was being protested
against say and worn by the university
about what I was doing,
because it was hypothetically
contravening the law people went on my
site to find out what sort of person I
was.
And I had pretty much everything I'd
said to students in the last 30 years
taped and,
and ready for per what public viewing.
My website had already had about a
million hits then.
And um,
people got very interested in the
psychology and it's not surprising to me
because what I've been teaching since
1993 is I think unbelievably practical.
You know,
I'm clinical psychologist so I've always
been interested in trying to improve
people's mental health.
And I viewed putting the lectures online
as a,
as part and parcel of that.
It's like there were a lot of smart
clinicians in the 20th century.
They learned a lot about how you could
put your life together,
decrease anxiety,
decreased depression or in yourself more
effectively in your communication and
with regards to your longterm plans and
understand your dreams and position
yourself properly in the world.
And it's been a real pleasure and a
privilege to be able to bring that work
to the broader attention of wealth.
Now it's millions of people.
It's not surprising.
It helps,
you know,
I mean these people were geniuses.
So the fact that,
talking about what Freud,
Freud,
young Karl Adler,
Carl Rogers,
Abraham Maslow,
there's a slew of existential cycle
psychologist,
the 1950s humanists in the 1960s.
There's,
there's probably a dozen or so,
maybe 15 of great clinicians who laid
the groundwork really for clinical
psychiatry and also for clinical
psychology.
And they and,
and also develop well developed
psychotherapy and therapeutic
conversations as we know it,
like a emergent myths.
It must bear the inflection of the
culture in which it was conceived.
Uh,
this is why I am particularly interested
in the areas of psychiatry and
psychology that are resourced from,
uh,
older materials such as a methodology in
architecture.
And I know that particularly in,
in the,
some of the names that you mentioned,
mythology I used as a car to a supply,
a common language.
Yeah.
Well,
and that's,
that's the right way of looking at it to
some degree.
It's like people,
we act out stories.
That's why we tell stories,
right?
That's why people are attracted to
stories because stories are the best way
of describing our lives.
And stories have a pattern or they
wouldn't be stories.
I mean,
that's why there's comedy,
right?
That's where everything turns out the
way everyone wants it too.
That's why there's tragedy when
everything falls apart.
That's why there's adventure and romance
and that covers a lot of territory,
right?
Adventure,
Romance,
comedy,
tragedy,
and you know,
people like Carl Young in particular,
he was,
he was the deepest analyst of stories,
I would say.
Um,
there's a Romanian guy named Murcia,
Eliana,
who was also a very historian of
religions who was also very remarkable
scholar and very useful if,
if you're interested in understanding
the fundamental patterns of stories.
But young was very interested in the
deepest structure of stories.
Imagine that humans have languages.
Every human culture has a language,
but languages have a commonality,
right?
They're all languages.
And they have a universal grammar.
That was,
that was a noam Chomsky's great
discovery.
Yes.
And stories are like that.
Every culture has its own stories,
but the stories have a universal
grammar.
And so when was the first person who,
who laid the groundwork for,
for,
for discovering what that universal
grammar was.
And it's crucially important work.
No,
you could say that.
What a religious a religion is.
Is it a religion is a set of stories
that comes very close to the grammar of
stories so and so there aren't,
they aren't stories that you can
dispense with hero stories like that
you say did great early work in mapping
out what might be the etymology or the
sort of the Lt rhea truth from which
these patterns emerge?
Yep.
Um,
my interest,
this is that it
that cause look either when you're works
with image and Mandela in say for
example,
the red book for it's that what it's
what is suggested by our ability to
observe patterns and the fact that we
respond to patterns is that there is
that there is some kind of universal
frequency that we are responding to.
I had two clients who knew nothing about
union psychotherapy,
both of whom were badly fragmented.
They were both women.
They both had,
I would say variants of post traumatic
stress disorder.
They had other problems as well.
And both of them produced spontaneous
drawings that were first very fragmented
and disorganized.
And then as they put themselves together
and we're ordering themselves,
let's say they produce drawings that
were increasingly symmetrical and
regular and took on the Mandela like
configurations that young described.
And so that was absolutely fascinating
to watch that.
And he thought of those patterns as
manifestations of spontaneous order and
you'll see them in cathedrals.
Yes,
the great rose windows and cathedrals
are Mandelas and the rose windows and
the entire cathedral structure is
something like,
it's hard to describe exactly,
but a cathedral is something like the
optimal balance of structure and light.
It's something like that.
And the gothic cathedrals are also
reminiscent of forests,
right?
With their,
with their arching branches and the
light's coming through like the light
coming through the leaves.
It's reminiscent of that.
But there's something about the
cathedral that expresses the idea of
perfect structure and there's something
about a Mandela that expresses that and
something about music that expresses
that as well.
And it's all,
they're all ways of trying to
symbolically represent how things could
be if they were put in the proper state
of balance.
Harmony,
harmony is the right way of thinking
money.
Harmonies.
I suppose all of these forms,
the idea that there could perhaps be
across the various disciplines,
Straw or informs and expression,
some kind of golden rule seem to infer a
oneness,
a truth that in earlier forms of
language may be expressed as the idea of
God,
wholeness,
oneness.
Uh,
w where the,
what did he stand on the idea,
I do believe in God.
Well,
the union idea is that,
that there's not much distinction
between what young described as the
archetype of the self and the idea of
God and the self would be something like
that.
The totality of your being across time,
young thought of Christ as a symbol of
the self and the reason for that,
which is a very profound idea.
It's an amazingly profound idea.
Go and unpack it.
Well,
you can,
if you think about the,
the story of Christ from a psychological
perspective,
what,
and,
and you strip it down to its essence,
what you essentially see is that the
story of Christ is the ultimate tragedy.
And the reason for that is that the
ultimate tragedy is the worst possible
happening to the best possible person.
Right?
That's the ultimate tragic,
that's what makes it an archetype.
You can't go past that for tragic,
right?
So it's an innocent man who was
completely sinless,
who was working on behalf of,
of,
of only the good and the truth.
Broken and destroyed early and young and
betrayed as well.
So that's the ultimate tragedy.
And so then,
and then there's a,
there's a common,
a comedic element to it in the technical
sense,
cause a comedy has a happy ending.
Clay wouldn't even require a full in a
light for the,
for the,
for,
for it to work immediately.
There would need to be a flow in Christ.
Is it that he has God made flesh?
Is that the floor?
Well,
there it depends on what you mean by
comedy.
I mean we,
we tend to as modern people to think of
comedy as something that's humorous.
But technically if you're looking at
story structure or comedy is just a
story that has a happy ending,
right?
That has a positive ending and that
source,
it's The resurrection story that makes
Christ's story a car,
a comedy.
Tada.
Exactly.
Yeah.
This went so badly wrong.
But there's this possibility of
resurrection and the way that I read
that psychologically,
and I'm not trying to make any comments
about the metaphysics of it,
is that there's a part of people that's
the self,
the young self,
let's say cap the SLV council as self.
Yes.
That that is capable of sustaining
itself across success of deaths and
rebirths and everyone really understands
this.
It's one of the things that's most fun
to teach people because you know when,
when you're moving through life and you
have a plan or a dream and it shatters,
you know,
someone dies or a relationship breaks
apart or you,
you have a terrible upset in your career
or you become ill in some unexpected way
that everything around you falls apart
and you plunge into a while,
you plunge into a chaotic underbelly of
the way.
That's exactly right.
Yes,
exactly that.
And then you,
maybe you stay there because it isn't
necessarily the case that people get
out.
You know,
people die.
People are in despair permanently,
but frequently something tragic and
terrible be false.
You and you fall apart and you learn
something profound as a consequence.
And you put yourself back together and
when you come back out,
you're more than you were when you went
in.
And that's happening at a small scale.
Every time you learned something,
you know,
you,
if you ever really learned something,
it's usually painful.
It usually means that you have to
recognize that you're wrong in some
important way.
You have to let that part of you that's
wrong,
die.
And then you have to let a new part of
you,
okay.
So the self,
imagine that you undergo a series of
transformations in your life.
There are,
there are collapses into the chaotic
underworld and then red mini
resurrections that happens continually.
And that's what molds your character is
his self,
is this thing that manages the
transformations across all those across,
that manages all those transformations.
So you could say,
here's another way of thinking about it.
He could identify with what you
understand.
That's what idiot logs do.
You could identify with you dealt with
what you don't understand and that's
what sort of seekers after truth,
um,
uh,
identify with,
or you could identify with the process
of moving between those states.
You know,
sometimes you know what you're doing,
you know where you are,
you,
you're,
you're in control and,
and,
and you can become arrogant and identify
without,
and then become too static about it.
Right?
Or you can be in despair and everything
is chaotic and you all can identify with
that,
in which case you're not allistic.
Or you can view yourself as the thing
that moves across the transformations
and that's,
that's the right way to,
to,
to conceptualize yourself as you're,
the thing that maintains constancy
across transformations.
One imagines that your experience,
uh,
with the controversies around the,
linguistics and legislation in Canada
must have felt like one of those plunges
into the depths on some level.
Would you say,
did you,
did you feel a sense of personal tragedy
and fear and a concern about consequence
or that there may be no way back that it
could represent a kind of death or did
it indeed represent a kind of death for
you,
for one for which you are subsequently
grateful?
Well,
I would say for the first four months
when the political scandal broke,
it was very unsettling for a variety of
reasons.
The first was that my occupation as a
clinical psychologist and as a professor
was definitely in doubt.
I mean,
the university sent me two warning
letters and that's standard hr
procedure.
Usually you get three,
right?
The third warning is stop or their
consequences won't be good.
If you work in human resources,
you have to,
especially if you're going to go after
someone with tenure,
you have to document their misbehavior.
You have to provide them with warnings.
You have to tell them how they could get
back on the right track,
and then if you have documented refusal
to comply with the warnings,
then they have grounds for dismissal.
You were close,
you were close.
You were close today.
Yeah,
to some kind of personal or professional
annihilation or certainly damaged.
Now those for a bit,
just in case on the off chance that
there are people that are unaware of the
d hours.
I'll say it as I understand it and then
you can tell me I've got it wrong.
The government changed the law say and
that there are neutral nouns that will
be mandatorily would be applied to
people that identify as transgender.
You said that is an imposition on
freedom of speech.
Whilst I would make a decision whether
or not I would,
if I was meeting a transgender person,
I would talk to them how they want it to
be talked to.
The fact that you're making it law is an
impediment on the freedom of speech and
then kicked
off.
Yeah,
that's,
that's a,
that's a good summary of it.
Yeah.
I would say,
I mean my sense there were two things
are objected to.
One was that the government for the
first time in the history of Canada and
really in a move that was unprecedented
in English common law under English
common law actually mandated the content
of voluntary speech and I thought,
I don't care what your excuse is for
doing that.
That's no go zone.
Far as I'm concerned.
That's not happening
even though,
right.
This is what it seems to me like sort of
helped me to understand this one
because,
well,
I'm always interested in I think is
power and where power is.
Yeah.
Like you know,
subsequently look what your views are
towards that sort of poststructuralist
and the ot left and like a lot of things
I think.
Yeah,
you're right.
That though,
you know,
I,
I agree with that,
but what,
but what I,
the reason I think that the sort of the
controversy had fuel on both sides.
The reason it had an engine on the other
side is because it seems that,
uh,
and indeed having watch I've interviews
and the objections that other
interviewers have presented to you,
it seems to me that like,
it seems that our transgender person is
in a position of vulnerability,
but you are saying this is not about
transgender,
this is about language and it's about
oppression.
That's what you're saying.
That was my claim is that this wasn't
about transgenderism at all.
And Yeah,
I'm about mate.
You've got no strong view,
I'm guessing or,
um,
I don't,
I don't have the sort of strong view
that I would,
what,
think I was sufficiently qualified to
make political statements about,
yeah.
Lecture.
Kyle goes,
I don't understand it,
but she's not my boy,
basically.
Yeah.
Look at the research.
You know what I mean?
The research for transgendered kids is
quite clear,
is that most of them deceased by the
time they're 18,
you know,
and I'm basically guided by,
wait,
does he know Scandinavia where they
check that stuff out?
Yeah,
yeah,
that's right.
That's right.
No,
people have criticized that research,
like all research,
but it's the best research that's been
done on the topic.
But on the other problem was with the
legislation was that I felt that it was
an attempt by the radical left to gain
the linguistic territory and to define
that the terms of the debate,
you know,
and,
and I thought that was very dangerous,
so I was objecting to that as well.
Phil,
you never will.
The thing that I'm interested in here,
Jordan,
is I don't feel like the radical left is
a very powerful group.
Am I being naive here?
I mean possibly in the world of academia
that I feel like they are sort of
representative of a coalition bill
around identity politics issues that
would seem particularly important to
people.
Like my general view is if you identify
something,
call no problem.
It sounded my business.
That's basically my opinion.
I'll,
I'll call you what you want me to call
you.
I'm happy that you're speaking to me,
but like,
but do you see as sort of of the uh,
sort of the sort of extreme left or as a
powerful organization like certainly in
the universities he said,
well they can get what done they could
for example,
they'll get that legislation passed.
Yes.
That the woman,
I think the situation is different in
the u s than it is in other countries.
I think the political situation in the u
s is actually more balanced than it is
in most western countries because I
would say the,
the left,
the radical left has a,
has a pretty decent hold on a number of
institutions and,
and first and foremost of those would be
the universities.
But then the conservatives,
you know,
aren't without power in the United
States because they occupied most of the
elected positions.
Now do you use it,
but it's not the case in Canada.
You didn't want to be identified with
any of those groups,
am I right?
Like you wouldn't say that you're a
person that's on the right or the left
or conservative or really,
I know she didn't say whether or not you
believed in God.
Well,
my political views are complicated
because I'm temperamentally liberal
cause I'm pieing openness,
which is a creativity dimension.
People who are high in openness tend to
be liberal because they liked free
flowing information and they like,
uh,
what would you say?
Fluid boundaries because information can
move back and forth across the
boundaries.
So reject like that
ideologically you reject to these
taxonomies and you identify basically on
the bay on the basis of research like
empiricism.
In a sense you could say like you know,
I'm an open minded type of person.
This language is clinical psychology,
so really your faith is clinical
psychology.
Well I've done a fair bit of research in
my lab on yes,
the temperamental predictors of
political predisposition and we can
predict what parties people are going to
align themselves with by studying their
personality.
So liberal types,
liberal left types are high and the
trait called openness and open people
here are very open person and you can
tell because you think laterally,
you know you have an idea and then it
reminds you of a whole bunch of other
ideas and so you'll move laterally
across ideas and a more conservative
person,
they'll stay within the category,
you know?
And so your,
your conversational style is is mark,
bye bye divergences.
That's,
that's actually called divergent
thinking.
It's a hallmark of great,
good.
Well it's good if you want to be
creative.
The problem with them,
there's a price for everything.
Hey,
the price for creativity is that it's
hard to catalyze an identity because
you're interested in everything.
That's the first thing and your
interest,
we'll flip from one thing to another.
So one of the problems that creative
people have while they have two,
one is they have a hard time
establishing an identity.
And the second is they have a hard time
monetizing their creativity.
It's very difficult to be a creative
person and make money.
You can make money for other people,
but usually your dad by then,
so it's not very helpful for you do it.
And both of those problems,
uh,
as a result of external structures,
the imposition of external structures on
the individual iee make money.
That's a problem of capitalism and you
know,
commerce more broadly.
And uh,
the other one of identity similarly,
you know,
so there is,
is there a sort of a peculiar
contradiction in,
uh,
around identity in that like it seems to
me on one level that you reject
taxonomies.
So you're saying that these systems,
eeg,
if you say women are being paid less
money,
your argument would be,
well,
hold on a minute.
There are other factors other than Jack
Gender it here.
I exactly agree with the data.
It's a funny thing because the
intersectional feminists always,
uh,
always claimed that you should take
other factors into account.
Right?
Woman man isn't enough.
Yeah.
Black isn't enough when I say,
well there's a,
there's a pay gap between men and women,
but it's not only do due to gender,
it's due to all sorts of things and you
have to take them into account.
So it's an intersection of argument.
So it's quite funny that I get hell for
it.
He's an intersectional argument.
So unlike,
so do you feel that,
cause what I sent you happening,
like trying to understand where like our
worldviews would align where potentially
there would be opposition between you
and I?
Well,
I'm trying to think cause it seems to be
looking at your work,
you said,
oh I don't agree with the way that this
information is being compiled.
I don't agree with the assumptions that
you're trying to saddle that piece of
data with.
It seems to me that it's about critical
thinking and very post structuralist
idea,
you know?
Um,
but it also,
what I have noticed is that much of
your,
many of your theories seem to be
subsequently,
uh,
Lloyd to some unpleasant ideas around
there's sort of tradition and
conservatism,
oppression even.
How do you feel about that?
Cause like,
you know,
like it would be like,
it'd be well easy for you to laugh.
I think you have said,
I don't care about whether pete was
transgender or not.
I just don't want no oppressive laws
around language builders.
It'd be easy if you'd say,
I don't think there's any,
you know,
I've heard you say on the news,
fairness,
but it does seem that there was some
mischief somehow in near around the
issues such as gender inequality,
mischief and me,
Rhonda,
all sorts of things.
But I think that mostly I look at the
political landscape from the perspective
of a informed biologically oriented
social scientists.
And so when people lay out their
particular theories,
um,
they don't sound,
they don't sound outdated to me.
Like one example is that the left,
for example,
tends to lay the blame for inequality at
the feet of the western hierarchical
structure and capitalism.
And that's just wrong.
Equality inequality is a problem and
it's the proper concern of the left,
I would say.
And it's a proper concern because
inequality is a deadly problem,
but it's way more serious than anything
you can blame on capitalism.
Every single society that's ever been
studied for as far back as people are
able to study suffers from the problem
with inequality.
This,
I work with this native American tribe
in,
in northern Vancouver.
I'm a member of the tribe actually now
they're called the [inaudible] people.
And uh,
say that again,
that's not sort of like I have to say
much qua qua qua qua qua wok.
Oh,
I see.
Yeah.
Tough bear for their native language.
Right.
Tough one to spell cause I would
probably with me is would say too many
class
then they're brick.
They're,
they're brilliant artists.
They're part of that west coast native
tradition of art,
which I think is a great tradition.
Is that,
um,
well exaggerated eyes.
I want,
it's Hulu.
It's kind of a hallucinogenic art in
some sense.
And these family,
the animals are very,
are,
are very,
uh,
graphic.
They're very graphically portrayed,
I would say they have large almond eyes
and bright colors and um,
the arts fared beautiful.
The hideout art is probably the best
known,
very intense.
But the Kwakwaka'Wakw is,
is similar to that.
So they used to have this ceremony
called the potlatch.
And what you would do in a potlatch is
usually you have to be comparatively
wealthy to have a part latch and you
would give away everything you had.
And that was their solution to
inequality because what would happen in
the native societies,
just like every other society,
is that as time progressed everything
would become owned by a very small
number of people.
And that's a bad recipe for longterm
stability.
So they would have these giant parties
that would often last weeks where the
rich would demonstrate their wealth.
And also,
I suppose their commitment to their own
provision,
their own capacity to provision the
future by giving everything away.
But,
and I'm only using that as an example to
show that the problem of inequality,
it's not something that you can lay at
the feet of capitalism.
It's a way worse problem than that.
I agree with you and I understand,
uh,
but you're saying that
capitalism occurs far too late down the
line to be the genesis a problem that's
indigenous to the but what about some of
these like,
you know,
and I would be very careful to like the,
I don't know.
I'm saying I believe in God,
I believe in God,
but like I wouldn't politically,
I would be a little more cautious about
saying why I agree with this pilot boat.
Cause I sort of don't feel that my
political views are demonstrated within
the sphere of mainstream politics
because they operate on such a
prohibited frequency because of the,
yeah,
the power of Trans National
Organizations,
the irrelevance of national sovereignty
when it comes to ordinary people
asserting power.
So,
you know,
it becomes sort of kind of too complex
for me.
But what I can see is interesting about,
so you know even if you take a sort of
socialism and perhaps you know like the,
I suspect or sense that one of the
issues you take is it sort of continual
annihilation of likes it take first,
take out God,
then take out man and take out woman,
then take out everything to all we have
is this miasma of meaninglessness.
I wouldn't necessarily put that at the,
well,
I wouldn't necessarily put it in read
the socialism
per se.
What would you say that is?
Well that's a complicated one.
I mean it happening or did it?
Am I wrong?
I think,
I think it's happened in many ways.
I think a lot of that is a consequence
of the hypothetical conflict between
science and religion.
Do you think that's hypothetical?
What would be,
because I'm not so sure there is a
conflict.
There will look their materialism and
spiritual fundamental conflict because
the world is one thing fundamentally,
right?
Everything fits together so there can't
actually be a conflict.
If the religious realm exists in the
scientific realm exists,
they have to be unifiable at some point.
Now the more materialistic scientists or
the what the more atheistic scientists
types like Sam Harris would deny
essentially that there's any validity to
religious dogma.
Although he certainly believes that
there's a element to life.
So I think that what happened,
at least in part,
and this is why the work of Yom to
return to yoga so important is that we,
we weren't,
we didn't understand that truth comes in
different forms depending on its
application.
It's a tricky thing.
There's the truths that apply when
you're attempting to describe the
transformations of the material world
and there's the truths that apply when
you're trying to determine how it is
that you should act while you're alive.
And those,
obviously those have to come into
alignment,
but they're not in alignment right now.
And my sense,
and this is the sense that's being
developed at least in part from reading
the great psychoanalysts,
is that fictional accounts,
Mehta,
fictional accounts,
even like biblical comps,
which are mythological our stories about
how it is that people should act.
Not Stories about what the material
structure of the world is like.
This is also where the fundamentalists
have it wrong as far as I'm concerned.
Because the fundamentalists like to
think that the,
the account in genesis is a scientific
theory.
It can be stacked up against other
scientific theory.
She'll,
they are materializing the mythic.
Yes,
that's right.
And this says I'm helpful.
Well,
it's not a help.
first of all,
it's not,
it doesn't even make any sense because
the materialist types in any real sense
weren't around until about 500 years
ago.
Right.
And this was all satisfy like cart and
the cart and,
and uh,
um,
bacon and,
well,
Galileo was another player,
but those were the two.
The two major players established the
scientific method.
There weren't scientists before then.
I mean,
there were very intelligent people who
could analyze the structure of the
world.
The ancient Greeks were obviously very
rational and capable of philosophy,
but there was no science until 500 years
ago.
And so obviously the people who wrote
genesis word scientists,
because there weren't any scientists,
so whatever.
And I also think that the,
the world they describe is much more,
it's much better considered the world of
experience than the world of material
reality.
And well,
look here,
here's an idea.
You,
you can,
you can try this one on for size.
I've been trying this on audiences for
quite a long time.
So modern people say they think the
world is made out of things,
but if you watch them,
that's not how they act.
They act like the world is made out of
potential.
And so they'll even say things to each
other like,
you're not living up to your potential.
You might say,
well,
what is this potential that you're
talking about?
You can,
it doesn't have a color.
It doesn't have a shape.
It doesn't have a mass.
It doesn't have a size.
Like there's nothing about it that's,
it has a material,
a material element.
Yet you believe that you're not living
up to your potential.
Everyone feels guilty about that.
If someone accuses you,
if that you feel bad about it.
So then I might say,
well,
you also live not as if you confront a
world of things,
but as if you confront a world of
possibility and you hold each other
accountable that way.
Cause I could say,
well,
you're not making all the use of the
possibility that's presented to you
because you're not living,
you're not living.
Honestly.
You're not aiming high enough.
You're not making everything of that
potential that might be made.
It's what's that potential?
Well,
in religious stories,
that potential,
and you see this in the first story in
genesis,
is that potential is what God creates
order out of at the beginning of time.
That's the idea that's expressed in that
book is that there's a potential,
whatever that is,
and that something acts on it to bring
it into reality.
And there's a deeper idea in there too,
which,
which is a profound idea,
which is that the potential,
the actuality that you bring out of
potential with truth is good.
And so there's an ethical element to the
story as well.
And I actually think that that's,
that's a great truth.
I do believe that's the case,
that the reality you bring out of
potential with truth is good.
And I think that's one of the most,
that's one of the most profound
discoveries of humanity.
The ability to articulate that idea was
articulated in the first chapter in
Genesis to brilliant idea that's
associated with the idea that human
beings are made in the image of God
because God is that which calls reality
into being out of potential.
But each of us do that as well in a
small way.
That seems to me to just be true.
Of course,
all the things that are in the manifest
world where once unmanifest,
right,
and many of the things that are
unmanifest now will become manifest and
we could choose that to some degree.
We have agency.
Well,
we seem to treat each other like
we do.
Yeah,
well,
you know,
if I treat you like you don't have
agency,
you don't like it.
It's not the grounds for a,
for a satisfactory longterm
relationship.
While we were in the Old Testament,
I want to ask you something because you
want to pick a job that seems right up
your alley.
I looked at this book,
I can't remember about any more.
You may even know specs that you,
you will,
it was a book of engravings from the
Book of job by the British writer and
poet William Blake.
Blake had done the series of engravings
based on the trials and tests that Joe
went through in these,
in these series of engravings.
Yourway and Joe,
I,
y'all way and joe are depicted as a sort
of identical,
you know,
the ones in a celestial realm once in a
terrestrial realm and the beginning of
the image.
But Joe and his family are depicted in
front of the tree of life,
the instruments hanging in the trees.
The animals are sleeping by the end of
the image after these various trials,
you know,
after Joe has been tested this,
and we were to assume,
I suppose that there's been this journey
of self,
capital s realization.
I mean,
uh,
of a,
through these trials,
uh,
the,
the instruments are being played to the
animals are awake,
you know,
and there's a sort of a bright future in
this sense of astronomical stuff I
either position in at the sun and moon
is somehow meant to be significant also.
And the person that wrote this book,
he's a union.
Now,
the thing that struck me deep,
deep,
and I've been struggling with it ever
since,
is there's a moment where Yar way shows
the behemoth and the to job.
And he says,
these I made is I made the right.
And then in this union analysis of these
engravings,
the writer says that God requires of us,
that we be good,
that goodness itself may exist,
that there is a something beyond,
but it's comparable to neutrality in
God,
the Creator,
the idea of God,
the creator,
the image of the behemoth and the
Leviathan in these engravings is
terrifying.
The animalism of the bacchae empathy,
it's Musculature,
its rawness,
the Leviathan,
sneaky,
dark,
deep,
terrifying thing.
This idea of agency and got this
relationship between the unmanifest and
the manifest as achieved through an
individual's relationship with truth and
expression seemed to me that it was
saying something that was right on the
precipice of my ability to understand
and sandy to convey.
Okay.
So the first thing I would say as well,
one of the indications that you're open
is the way that you phrased that
question cause there's like 30 things
happening in that question all at the
same time.
And one of the things that creative
people do is they throw out like images
and cause your,
your,
your question was full of images.
There's,
you're trying to map territory that you
don't understand.
You say here's an image and here's an
image and here's the new bridge and
here's an image.
And there's something uniting all of
those.
But I don't know what it is.
It's like,
well that's what artists do by the way.
And so that's a preliminary mapping of
unexplored territory.
And so we could take that apart a little
bit.
I mean,
one of the things,
so joe is objecting to his treatment
because of course God has a bet with the
devil basically,
that he can take job down and make them
curse fate.
He basically bets the devil that he can
turn job into Kaine and God says,
no,
you God says no,
you the devil bets God that he can turn
job indicate by tormenting him and God
says,
no jobs a good man.
No matter what you do to him,
he won't lose faith in being.
That's essentially the bat.
And you think,
well that's a hell of a thing for God to
do.
But then,
and job objects to God to some degree
and he's got his reasons,
man.
I mean cause everything's taken away
from him and God says,
I made these things,
the Leviathan.
So that's like the terrible element of
nature.
And I made the bay a moth and maybe you
could say that's the terrible element of
society.
It's like how dare you question me?
And that's a perfectly reasonable
objection.
It's like really?
You're good at it doesn't matter what
happens,
you're going to question God really
well.
So God objects to that and then and then
you,
you will,
although job young believed that job
actually had the moral upper hand in
that description because God behaved
rather reprehensive Lee and having a bet
with the devil.
I mean young wrote a book called answer
to job,
which is very much worth reading.
It's quite a profound piece of work.
But then you also woven into the
question this idea of the ethical
requirement to be good.
Yes,
there's something in that that's
unutterably deep because this is,
this is right at the limit of my ability
to understand things too.
So it's speculative beyond belief,
but it seems to me that we are thrown
challenges and that they're,
that that in some sense those are best
construed as tests of our ethical
ability.
So what human thought,
his idea,
it was something like this that at the
beginning of time people were
unconscious and that consciousness
emerge with all of its catastrophes,
consciousness of death for example.
And one way out of the burden of
consciousness was to return to
unconsciousness.
You can do that with alcohol.
You can do that by being dependent.
You can do that by failing to grow up.
You refuse the burden of consciousness
by becoming unconscious again.
But there's another way for which is to
become even more conscious.
So the idea would be a little bit of
consciousness is like an illness,
but if you can expand that consciousness
upwards enough,
then it's stumps something.
It starts to become something that it's
all that is its own cure and that partly
what your goal is while you suffer
through life is to heighten your
consciousness to the point where
everything gets integrated enough so
that that's proper medication for the
disease of self consciousness.
And you don't believe that that was
really the,
that was one of the ideas that ran
through the entire while the entire
structure of Judeo Christianity,
although not it wouldn't be limited to
Judaeo Christianity.
So it's,
it's more consciousness rather than
less,
it's more attention and I,
I think,
I think there's something to that and
some of that.
See.
The other thing you see in
psychotherapy,
for example,
is that when you're trying to lead
people forward out of the darkness,
let's say out of anxiety and depression
and despair and resentment,
bitterness and anger and all of those
things,
catastrophic interactions with their
family,
is that you get them to stop avoiding
confronting the terrible things that are
in front of them,
right?
So basically what you do,
instead of saying to them,
you know,
all those terrible things that are
happening,
just ignore those and,
and,
and find some peace,
right?
Get your mind away from it.
That isn't what you say you say,
turn around and look at them even more
than you've been looking at them.
It was a very paradoxical advice,
but of all the things that have been
proven to aid people's recovery and
movement towards mental health,
that's like at the top of the list,
voluntary confrontation with what you
are afraid of or,
or what you despise even for that
matter.
And so young had an axiom that he
derived from the alchemist,
which was in stir curliness infinite
tour,
which meant roughly meant that which you
most need will be found where you least
want to look,
which is fun.
Yeah,
well that's hit.
I was also his explanation for why
people weren't enlightened because you
think,
well,
the California approach to enlightenment
to speak,
you know,
kind of satirically is follow your
bliss.
It's like,
well that's easy.
If that was the case,
everyone would be enlightened.
But the union approaches,
no,
no.
You do what's meaningful and pay
attention,
follow the truth and it will take you to
the worst place you can imagine.
And then maybe there's some chance for
enlightenment.
Campbell somewhat revoked that,
uh,
I follow your bliss,
mantra though by saying he wish he'd
said follow your blisters.
You know,
like one of these,
the pain.
Yeah.
I didn't know he said that.
It's cool,
isn't it?
Yeah.
The kids pull out on the scoreboard.
That's good.
That's like a novel thing.
Oh,
now I've been framed because you've said
that I said something that you didn't
know.
And it's unraveled my entire veltin
shower.
And now I've reached for a bit of German
language to pull my way back in.
Oh yeah.
Heard and Melville,
he'll help me out.
Like so like a,
I'm reading this moby Dick,
it smashed my head up,
you know,
like,
and like,
um,
when he says in the,
there's a,
towards the end of the book I have,
when he's hanging out with pip and
stuff,
he's,
and he's really losing it now,
but maybe he's finding it too.
It is a bit weak.
He talks about will,
who is it that move this arm?
He says,
who is it that think disease thoughts?
If the mighty son has no control over
its movements,
what control is Ahab over his thoughts?
You know,
in talking about fate and destiny and
these ideas,
again,
seemed to me very potent,
powerful themes.
My,
the petitioner
with a great whale.
Right?
And that's,
that's the dragon of the abyss.
That's,
that's Moby Dick.
Cause it's,
it's the hero against the dragon of the
abyss.
And he's obsessed with it.
Right?
Well,
he shouldn't be obsessed with it.
It's,
it's,
it's what to be obsessed with is the
dragon of the abyss.
That's the oldest story of mankind is
that your proper obsession is the dragon
of the abyss.
That's where the gold is.
Yes.
Even though that's where things are most
terrified,
bloody tragic ending,
except that you take Ishmael is the
protagonist,
in which case you should mount survives.
And I have,
you know,
done a ruin it for anyone dice.
Um,
but like I,
so it's a tragedy.
It's a tragic encounter with the dragon
of chaos.
He's a failed hero.
Fundamental outcomes.
He's a,
and he's gay.
Lost that limb and stuff and I'm sure,
yeah,
sort of a symbolic,
just like Captain Hook and the
crocodile,
he had a half the ha.
Yeah.
I love,
for me it's very exciting when I see
these patterns of preventing Elysium.
For me it is exciting because this tree,
it's the implicit energy and implicit in
his truth.
And now that thing we were talking about
a minute ago where we were,
I got excited because I said fully your
blisters,
the field's going to say is like that.
So some sort of maximize understand in
Buddhism of like let it burn,
let it burn and burn,
like take away from me everything.
Right?
Right.
Oh there's the idea is also
there in Christianity,
so there's no cult interpretation.
There's letters on Christ's cross Inri
Jesus Christ.
It means Jesus Christ,
King of the Jews.
And it was put there by the Romans.
But there's no cult interpretation in
Latin,
which I can re re reproduced,
but it means through fire,
all things are renewed.
And one of the,
one of the deepest ideas of Christianity
is that you should burn everything off.
That's part of you that isn't part of
that thing that can die and be reborn.
Like there's all sorts of baggage that
people say that there's baggage that
you're carrying.
Everyone knows that it's deadwood.
It's like that to burn off.
And that's a lot of,
that's way more of you than you think.
She was.
Way More than you think.
Whilst you still haven't said whether or
not you believe in God,
and I won't keep going on about it
because I'm not one of them.
People see what the means to do that.
So let,
I'm like,
it seems to me that you revere truth at,
it seems to me that you are interested
in the truth in scripture and mythology.
Now then what this leads me to is
something we've touched upon briefly.
It's about the role of power and the
function of morality and ethics and,
and,
and indeed simpler ideas that will have
terms if not ideas such as compassion
and goodness.
So when like,
you know,
it's interesting to me that you've
written sort of an accessible sort of
self help type book that,
you know,
clean your room,
stand up straight,
stick your shoulders back,
stuff that,
you know,
like I would not query there.
The only thing that I feel like I would
like to ask you about because my,
I don't know if I even have a
constituency,
but the people,
I find that,
you know,
I find myself talking a lot to Muslim
people,
uh,
young women's self harming,
eating disorders,
these kind of clinical psychology.
So I imagine you have more and more
access to that kind of information and
those kinds of experiences than I do.
I have this strong feeling that I am
supposed to make myself available for
the vulnerable,
for the powerless and for the voiceless.
So that's a fine idea.
This is the one,
it's how do you do it?
How do huge bloody question.
Sometimes they don't want me interfering
in their lives majority of the time.
Right.
There certainly is that while there's
an,
there's a maxim that's often applied by
people who work in old age homes,
which is never do anything for the
residents that they can do themselves.
They can't still their own money and
they're sleeping.
Bobbie,
I'm a Canadian comedian.
Very funny that it was,
I think something that has paid off over
the long run.
Yeah.
Now,
so isn't it?
So it's hard.
Like the thing about,
the thing about compassion is it's not
sufficient to produce solutions.
Compassion is an unbelievably useful
emotion if you're dealing with six month
old infants,
they're always right.
She's there and also now,
but like a,
you know what?
I was taught very
well.
You said it doesn't work.
What
about what want to say is like,
I know you said no,
this thing about sort of good,
but one of the,
as a one off the essential themes,
ideas about the Christ myth being,
you know,
sort of burn away all that cannot be
reborn but bloody hell mate in the
actual language,
all he bangs on about is kindness,
kindness,
love,
revelation.
Not In revelation.
He's a judge in revelation.
What and are you still,
you're still taking that is what's books
beyond the gospels,
you're still taking as the word of
Christ.
Well,
I'm taking them as part of the entire
Corpus of the story.
I mean the reason that you thought
revelation was appended to the Bible is
because the Christ in the gospels was
aired two s too much in sense on the
side of mercy and not enough on the side
of judgment.
Because here's the technical,
there's a technical reason.
You know,
it's like we've got one attachment.
Oh Jesus.
Well,
you don't have a choice because if you
have an ideal,
it's a judge.
Like you have an ideal and there might
be an ideal that you have a view.
It's simultaneously your judge because
you fall short of it.
I understand this cause that's funny
enough,
I was talking to the fellow that taught
me meditation yesterday,
Bob Roth.
So he's a student of the Maharishi.
You know that.
He said that when Maharishi was asked
what is the one principal,
the one principal,
he didn't say kindness or compassion or
anything like that.
He said,
discernment,
and which path are we going to follow?
Their attention,
guarding,
but judgment.
That's why in revelation Christ divides
the damned from the saved and most of
the damned bitch discernment.
And what that means in some sense is
that there's a thousand,
there's 100,000
ways to do things wrong and only one way
to do them right.
Or maybe only five ways of doing them
right.
But you know that in your own life is
that the,
the,
there's an infinite number of snares
that you can tangle yourself up in and
to find that pathway where everything is
balanced,
that's very,
that requires continual discernment at
attention.
And so you,
you can't have an ideal without it being
a judge and you can't,
you can't live property without
discernment.
But that doesn't mean compassion and
compassion isn't relevant.
It doesn't mean that at all.
A guy ask you something that sort of
occurs to me.
See,
like,
I like you,
I found myself in different types of
controversial situations,
various conflict and many,
much of the time is because,
uh,
like Albert maysles said,
tyranny is the deliberate removal of
nuance.
People remember,
I didn't even say that.
That's a good phrase.
It's good shit,
isn't it?
But like the thing,
right?
Deliberate removal of a new audience.
Yeah,
that's,
that's what makes it different than
ignorance because ignorance,
there's no nuance and ignorance,
but it's excusable because you just
don't know any better.
But when it's deliberate,
that's a whole different story.
It's very nice.
Who said the album mays was filmmaker
who made like grey gardens.
He made that be,
I did a documentary with him very
briefly and he uh,
he made that Beatles movie when the
Beatles first came to the states.
He made gimme shelter as the maze was
probably that I like old guys now.
Brilliant Documentarian,
uneasy.
I'm crew here and nodding the approval.
He invented much of the fly on the wall
verite style that's informed subsequent
documentary tyrannies that deliver it.
Removal of nuance.
I worked with him sort of briefly
filming none other than President Donald
Trump of all people.
But like one of the things that I wanted
to talk about was,
um,
if I like this is the thing,
I don't like all of the,
I don't like the,
I agree and I or I feel,
I don't know what you feel that,
that you know,
that one of the,
the,
the neo liberalism abandoned its
allegiance to and leftist politics.
It has in a sense abandoned the working
class and I can understand their rage
and,
but the feeling I personally have is
when,
if I sense that I'd said things and I've
done this so I know that have offended
women,
which I,
you know,
when I was more,
when I was a single person that was
promiscuous,
I know that that course be comfort,
aggression and conflict.
Or when I've done things like,
you know,
in the spirit,
a few mother of cat,
like a kickback.
I've always felt bad.
If I feel like I've offended people,
the I would,
I would regard or culturally or regarded
as vulnerable.
Yup.
So like around the,
uh,
like I,
when we make the conversation about the
use of language,
tyranny and oppression in free speech,
you know,
obviously I agree with you,
but the,
but I do take from,
you know,
the Gospel version of Christ,
the idea that kindness,
love,
we can't,
we have to continue to find resources
for ongoing,
you know,
I will continue to fail,
but we must continue to be loving.
So I'm,
my question is,
is if you are found herself in a
position where I kind of think some
people were using you to sort of say
fuck you women or fucking you
transgender people.
And for me I think I would want to still
go on.
That's not my bag.
So where do you stand on that?
Well,
I think,
I think that,
first of all we'll go to the most
fundamental part of the question,
which is this issue about love.
Then like one of the things I've thought
about a fair bit is the meaning of the
sermon on the mount.
And as far as I can tell,
it's,
it's a,
it's basically a two part.
It's two part wisdom.
The first is that you should aim at the
highest good that you can imagine.
And that would be a good,
that includes everyone,
right?
So if I wanted what was good for you,
say if I genuinely wanted it,
I wanted in a way that was good for you
now and good in the long run and good
for you and your family and your
community.
And maybe good for me too.
You know,
we could conceive of that as the desire
and I think that's a good definition of
love is that you actually want the best,
you want the best possible outcome.
And in the Gospels of course that's
extended even to your enemies.
Yes,
right?
Is that okay if we're going to have
things good,
let's have a good enough for even the
people that set themselves up against
me.
Because if the world was running
property,
things would be good for them too and
that would be better.
And it seems to me that that's a very
good way of looking at things.
It's a difficult way of looking at
things.
And then the second part of the sermon
on the mount is something like having
established that as your aim,
which is no easy thing by the way,
right?
Because you have to be pretty clear
headed and single minded to actually
want that to be rain.
Then you can concentrate on the day and
you can try telling the truth and you
can ally.
So there's truth and love that are
allied together.
Truth,
love and attention.
It's something like that that are all
allied together.
Um,
with regards to transgressing against
the vulnerable.
I don't think that that is what I've
done.
I think that people have claimed that,
but I don't think there's any evidence
for it.
I mean,
first of all,
I know absolutely that I have brought
perhaps thousands of people,
maybe tens of thousands of people,
but certainly thousands of people away
from identification with the right cause
they write me all the time and tell me
that I've received about 30,000
letters specifically from people who've
been watching my youtube videos since
August and 25,000
of them are.
So we've tried to count are from people
who said that they were in very dark
places and that their lives are much
better,
much oriented towards truth and
responsibility and a wave from political
ideology,
mostly on the right.
Right.
That they were attracted on the right.
Because I have more people like that.
Right.
Me Than people who say that I say
rescued them from the hell holes of the
radical left.
Um,
I think that's more of a historical
accident and some in some in some whites
than,
than anything else.
And but also with the transgender issue
and more specifically,
I've received now at least 40 letters
from transgender people and the only one
of them was critical and it wasn't that
critical.
The rest of them all said,
um,
we never signed up to be poster boy of
the year for the radical left.
And it's,
no,
it's been no picnic.
Believe me.
All that's happened is that our lives
have become much more difficult.
And I believe that and I don't see that.
I think one of the mistakes that the,
the radical left makes,
and this is part and parcel of their
flirtation with identity politics,
is that they fall all over themselves to
believe that if a person identifies as a
minority,
then they immediately have the right to
speak for all the people who are in that
minority.
And that's a claim that I reject
completely.
I mean,
first of all,
there is no transgender community.
It's not a community because the
community is constantly interacting and
networking and has a shared purpose.
And old out transgender people are just
as diverse as any other people.
It's like saying,
well there's,
there's no real black community,
there's not homogenous political
viewpoints across the black population.
I,
I agree to appoint the,
these taxonomies are necessarily
externally imposed because how would
they be intrinsically experienced?
I understand that.
But also it seems to me that there is a
thing called the experience of being an
African American and you can put into
that high prison populations for young
males,
lack of educational opportunity or work
opportunity that day is available for
that.
So while community may be an incorrect
term,
literally there is this,
there was a straw that seem to be
underserved.
And another concern I would have about,
so some of the war,
the re-purposing,
you know,
as far as far as we know so far or have
much of your arbitrary on online work
seems to me that it supports the
powerful is a ports hedge money.
I would,
I don't agree that things are as simple
as white men.
Our ability to pat and let you know that
you know,
like,
but I'm only interested in who is able
to effect change.
Who is able to influence,
who can you not attack in public?
What is possibly like,
who is being controlled?
That's what interests me.
So like in a transnational corporations,
economic elites,
you know,
like sort of,
and how are they serve by what I say or
by what you say.
Okay.
So that,
that's a reference back to the existence
of inequality.
We agreed or inequality back to that
problem.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
You're saying it's natural,
which clearly it's not.
You cannot leave it at the feet of
capitalism.
That's absolutely clear.
That and the fact that it's naturally
though capitalism,
what's that?
Capitalism doesn't help.
There's so many,
like in a Marxist critique,
what I understand that it is that
capitalism is built on limitless growth
from finite,
from finite resources.
And also capitalism will always,
always be redirected and criminally
misused.
And,
and they're sort of the economics of our
time.
It sort of for me is demonstrable.
I know stuff.
There are people that say,
oh no,
people are richer now than ever,
but like,
you know,
staying in La for a while and there's
90,000
homeless people in the Greater La area,
it seems like some sort of like the
apocalypse is creeping in.
People are richer than they ever have
been,
but the extreme extremes of inequality
are high too.
And there's some evidence that there's
some evidence.
Well here,
here's an example of how these things
might work.
So imagine that people,
that people are getting richer,
there's absolutely no doubt about that.
But here's,
here's what we got.
More stuff.
Even though like,
I'm sure you would agree that carving,
that's what starving,
that's good.
Obesity is a bigger problem in the world
now than starvation.
That's a big deal.
That's a big plus.
But here's the way it still implies that
people are being underserved by the sea,
by their operating systems.
Oh,
but there's no doubt about that.
And it's still in first inequality also.
Well,
first of all,
there's no doubt that any social system
has a tyrannical and arbitrary aspect.
I mean,
that's an architectural training,
right?
Any of course.
And even now,
even well functioning systems have a
tyrannical aspect.
Not mostly,
or at least merely because they're more
native Americans.
Who your gown.
We've not native Americans,
native Canadians that the Kwakwaka'wakw
then guys like how's their social system
set up?
Oh it's a catastrophe.
Go on.
Oh well I mean it's a catastrophe for
all sorts of reasons.
I mean some of it's true.
Yeah,
it is.
It is.
The situation is very catastrophic.
But you mainly because well the reserve
system was set up in Canada and it had a
possibility of working when there was a
possibility that small communities could
work economically.
But small communities don't work
economically anymore.
Like if you go through Saskatchewan for,
for example,
or central province in Canada in the
1960s there were thousands and thousands
of small towns,
mostly Caucasian.
That is because of their dots.
Capitalism.
No,
no it's not.
It's,
it's deeper than that.
It's the same prop.
Well here's,
it might be deeper than it,
but in its current form it is company.
Cause I would agree that,
what is capitalism a manifestation of
greed?
Well,
you could say,
well,
it's the same thing that,
but the same thing has happened all over
the world.
Like urbanization is taking places a
tremendously rapid rate.
It doesn't matter what the culture is or
the form of government.
So you think that the politics is
happening at a lower level.
The phenomenology,
that's where the,
where the significant is.
Ha Ha is a bigger time.
And within it,
political systems are just learning
about.
But that doesn't mean we shouldn't.
That's man.
All the ones we have in search a fairer,
more just better ones.
If typically,
if they are empirically not working,
come up with a way to reliably flattened
inequality,
that would be a good thing.
But the empirical evidence suggests so
there's a bunch of things it suggests.
First of all,
if you look at the,
at the attempts to alleviate inequality
over the last 200 years,
whether there were left wing governments
in power or right when governments are
made absolutely no difference whatsoever
to the degree of inequality,
the only things that have been reliably
demonstrated to flatten out inequality
are catastrophes,
wars,
revolutions,
epidemics.
Um,
there's one other war revolution
epidemics.
Well,
it's going to be some kind of holsman
now.
Yeah,
it starts right.
It's another horsemen,
and I can't remember which it is,
but,
but at a price of the price of radical
redistribution seems to death.
Yeah.
There and no one has come up with these
things because of how power functions.
Because like in a row,
in an unequal system,
whilst there are many people that are
suffering,
there are some people that are
benefiting.
I'm in a tear that benefit from their
current economic situation.
Um,
I drive a nice car.
I have nice house.
I go where I want.
Well,
let's look at that for a minute.
Like,
if you think about how that happened in
your life,
I bet I can tell you how it happened.
Well,
I mean,
if this isn't a personal account,
but Bennett Bay,
you hadn't assessed in one dimension,
right?
High success,
but because you were successful in that
dimension,
all sorts of opportunities came your
way.
Like my suspicions are that where you're
sitting now,
you have more opportunities than you can
deal with it.
Is that correct?
Yeah.
Right,
right.
Exactly.
Well,
the,
see,
this is part of what seems to drive
inequality is that as you get
successful,
the opportunities that come your way
start to multiply and they don't
multiply linearly.
They multiply exponentially.
And so when you start moving up,
you start moving up faster and faster
and faster and faster,
and then you'll hit a point where you
have so many opportunities that you
don't even know what to do with it.
And so it's a nonlinear improvement.
But the,
the,
the downside of that is you might've had
periods in your life that were like this
too,
where let's say you start to get
depressed and then you start to drink
because you're depressed and then you
start to isolate yourself because you're
drinking and you're depressed and
because you're drunk and depressed,
then your friends start to abandoned you
and then you lose your job.
It's like you're not going downhill in a
straight line.
You're going downhill faster and faster
and faster until you fall off a cliff.
And that seems to be how the world works
is like there's a center point,
it's unstable,
things improve,
then they improve exponentially and
things fall and then they fall off
exponentially.
And that seems to be what's driving
inequality.
You start to succeed and the probability
that you'll continue to succeed starts
to expand.
And we don't know how to control that.
And well here,
here's some other examples of it though,
because I said you couldn't lay it at
the feet of capitalism.
The same thing happens to cities.
A small proportion of the cities get all
the people.
So some cities grow like mad and others
fail catastrophically.
Like,
like Detroit,
it,
it applies to the massive stars.
So there's a very few stars in the Milky
Way that have most of the matter.
Hmm.
So it applies to the height of trees in
the,
in the jungle.
Right.
And do you think if things are
applicable in cosmology and in biology
the way that they are,
their application politically and
sociologically becomes less relevant
because you see these phenomena as being
broader,
then you don't know me don't keep an
interaction
less relevant.
I just see,
I don't think the left wingers are
pessimistic enough about the problem.
They say inequality is a problem.
It's,
yeah,
I did call is a problem.
Like it's,
it's a terrible problem.
But then they say,
well,
it's probably a function of our
political and economic systems and we
could fix those.
It's like,
no,
it's not a function of our political and
economic systems,
or if it is,
it's at such a deep level that we don't
know what drives it and we certainly
don't know how to control it.
Does that,
but does that not mean Jordan that would
you then reject any attempt to auto
systems in favor of fairness?
Because it seems to me that the focus is
on like,
and as it would be for clinical
psychologist,
individual change.
Now it's part of my personal experiences
without individual change.
Social change is sort of irrelevant and
many great gurus,
which you answered it right then and
there
because,
because I am concerned with inequality,
say saying with social instability and
I,
and I've thought about it for a long
time,
I knew that the left wing approaches
tended to fail catastrophic and the
right wing of course isn't particularly
concerned with inequality.
So that
left wing fails and the right wing don't
care.
Yeah,
that's right.
That's,
that's fun to see the danger
sufficiently and the right wing also
tends to think that the spoils go to who
deserves the,
yeah,
that's kind of true,
but it's not completely true.
So that's part of that because we're not
all because of course,
and what I like from a leftist
perspective would be that we're not
starting with from a level playing field
when the system isn't perfect at
selected.
And this is why I think a spiritual
solution,
but it's something that is beneath or
beyond material is the only way that
true progress is likely to be achieved.
I was thinking if there's something that
you said before about when we were
talking briefly about kindness and
compassion and it occurs to me and this
race program I'm sure very simplistic,
but the heroism itself,
by which I mean sacrifice,
the willingness to sacrifice yourself
for a greater idea.
What excites me about the idea now,
and I believe why the phenomena is so
loaded,
is if someone is willing to die for
something,
it's that they believe it's bigger than
them and in fact that themself,
their self is not the truest thing.
That there is something greater if I
will give my life for another person is
almost an acknowledgement of oneness.
The temporal illness of the individual
eight itself.
And we all worked so hard to achieve
individuation and I'm sure much of your
work as a clinical psychologist who's
guiding people towards it.
But for me it is just a,
uh,
temporary resting place because having
had the kind of experiences of personal
humiliation,
annihilation,
success,
failure for decimation here,
like you know,
all of these things,
but what,
what I've been led to and what I
continue to struggle with this,
how do I,
how do I serve?
How am I of service?
How do I help her though?
Do I think that that's,
that is the solution to the problem?
It's like,
I don't think the solution to the
problem of inequality is sociological.
I think it's psychological.
I mean,
partly what I'm
dry because it's closer to essence
because it's my essential,
oh,
because society has to be a reflection
of individual psyches or collective
psyches.
Why is it psychological temptation?
The temptation towards resentment and
destruction that's associated with
sociological approaches to inequality is
too great and that as a consequence,
those,
those movements,
10 inexhaustibly to become corrupt and
destructive began.
I think the orwell put his finger on it
when he said the middleclass socialists
don't like the poor.
They just hate the rich and that hatred.
I think that hatred gets the upper hand
in sociological movements.
I think that the best approach to
ameliorating inequality is to strengthen
the individual.
I mean that and that's,
and that's what I've concentrated on
doing what we have this program,
uh,
the self authoring suite and there's a
component of that that helps people
write an autobiography and another
component that helps them write an
analysis of their personality and
another component that helps them write
out a plan for the future.
And we've used that.
We've studied the effect of having
people write out a detailed plan for
their future and it's a proper plan.
It's like,
okay,
look,
you,
you get to have what you want three to
five years down the road.
You get to have the friends that you
want.
You get to have the family you want,
you get to have the career,
you want the education,
you get to take care of yourself
properly.
You get to withstand the temptations of
drug and alcohol abuse and other sorts
of impulsive pleasures.
You get to make productive and
meaningful use of your time.
Okay.
What does that look like for you?
Write it out,
what does it look like?
Do you need a vision?
And then you need another vision of how
terrible things could be if you let all
your bad habits get the upper hand.
And we've had people do that in an
experimental situation and most of them
are college students.
And the consequences of that,
there were two consequences.
One was general,
which was that university students who
were about 30% more likely to stay in
university and got grades,
there were were we're about 25% better.
This is a wall of pitting effect,
but even more interestingly,
and this is the coolest thing I think
that we ever discovered us in our,
in,
in our psychological research,
we did this research in Holland at the,
um,
uh,
at the Erasmus University in Rotterdam
at the Rotterdam School of Management.
And we ran business students through the
future authoring program for multiple
years.
So several thousands of them.
And we stratified them by gender and
ethnicity.
Pretty a pretty rough cut.
Men,
women and then Dutch nationals and non
Western ethnic minorities.
Okay.
And so that the performance was like
this.
The Dutch women were at the top.
Then the Dutch men,
then the,
then the non Western ethnic minority
women,
then the non Western ethnic minority men
and they were behind the Dutch women.
Bye Bye,
bye.
They they should about an 80% decrement
in performance.
Really quite catastrophic.
Two years after they did the future
authoring program,
they were ahead of the Dutch women.
It just blew us away because it was an,
it was a perfect indication of the fact
that you can use a psychological
intervention to ameliorate what looks
like a sociological problem and so I
think the right,
see,
I think the right solution,
and this is what I've been saying over
and over in my my lectures and in this
book,
12 rules for life and this is why I
think it's become so popular.
I said,
look,
you are right.
You are right.
You said earlier in the last question,
well,
you can't ignore the group
classification problem.
You know there's a black experience,
there's a Latino experience,
there's a female experience.
It's like,
yeah,
that's true,
but you have to decide what level of
analysis you're going to make primary.
And I think the primary level of
analysis is the individual and the
psychological rather than the group and
the sociological.
And I think if you put the individual
level first and then you alluded to that
cause it was,
it was like an intuition that you were
bringing forward,
which was your intuition has been that
the right level of progress is made at
the level of the individual.
And I think that's true.
I thought that's the end of the level
where I have personal authority and also
personal responsibility because the,
here's the thing,
like here's the rule,
how about this?
Don't recommend any changes that you
wouldn't suffer for if they failed.
How's that?
And that's the problem with large scale
political action.
It's like,
well,
here's how we should change things.
It's like,
well they changed them as well.
It fails.
It doesn't bother me.
It doesn't hurt me.
I'm not involved in it.
It's like you should be careful when you
try to change things.
Sure.
You suffered for your own stupid of
course.
Of course.
You wouldn't bet that that also plays
into the hands of conservatism because
you know when you said like that left
wing change tends to be sort of
potentially destructive.
These of course these are not just left
wing,
right wing radicals to and even not
yeah,
there.
And also there is sort of conventional
politics and the ecological impacts that
it has the inequality which are like,
whilst your setting,
you continued to say that the,
the problem of inequality is an
anthropological,
uh,
biological cosmological physical
problems to really deep problem.
It is a deep problem.
And for me,
whenever you get near a problem that has
that level of profundity or ubiquity,
the solution can only be spiritual.
We have to access the transcendent in
some way to look for solutions.
And although that sounds a little airy
fairy,
why do you believe that?
I mean,
I'm not disputing that,
but you obviously believe,
I do believe this.
What,
what drove you to that conclusion?
I've been driven to this conclusion by
the experiences of personal failure and
personal limitation by the failure of
individuation.
By the failure of of my own grandiosity,
the failure of my own ego,
the failure of fame and power and money
and sex and drugs that their inability
of them to reach me in the belly of the
beast.
Deep,
deep,
deep down.
Whether Leviathan is this,
these cures,
this alchemy was redundant.
And what I have realized,
I think there's the spiritual journey
for me,
the hero's journey in like,
you know,
I'm using reference points in which you
are an expert and a professor is that
that the death of the small s self and
the realization of the capital s self
means become a servant,
become a servant of good,
use your abilities to generate the
maximum amount of love,
the maximum about of mount of kindness
and compassion and to be alert to where
I can be of most use.
Now for me,
that can be incredibly limited because
I'm still a deeply egotistical,
narcissistic,
flawed,
failing individual.
But what my focus is,
what my intention is,
what I'm trying to learn to become in
this journey of self realization is a
compassionate and loving man.
So you added something to the tune
though.
Well you add useful to that.
Useful,
not useful as a finish.
That's it.
So the best definition of Christian
compassion that I ever read was useful
and generous.
Right?
Useful and generous.
Right.
And so I would say the Conservatives in
air,
the conservatives promote the useful end
of the distribution and the liberals pr
promote the generous set.
But I know things need to be brought to
you.
I would say.
And given that the,
you yourself have said the problem for
example of hierarchies exist on a far
broader spectrum than the political that
these than the narrow,
like when you were saying like on the
whole left wing Democrat or Republican
government or left wing,
right wing governments have produced a
similar amount of amount of inequality.
I mean that's sad.
It's,
I'm not happy about this.
I know.
Sad thing.
Doesn't it suggest also Jordan that the
range of solution that were being
offered is too limited?
Yes,
it,
I,
I don't think it suggests that.
I think it indicates that,
yes.
And this is why I think that the problem
of inequality has to be taken with more
seriousness than it's being taken.
And the role of the individual
[inaudible] obviously you would focus on
this as a clinical psychologist is
paramount because like,
cause I kind of believe when I think
about sort of a sort of a fluctuating
vivid grotesque right wing phenomena
such as Donald Trump,
I don't blame people for voting for
Donald Trump.
I understand why people feel furious.
I understand the emotion of anger and
rage and I suspect that all or all that
plays out in the Zoetrope of the
material realm is a reflection of the
activity in the psyche activity in
emotion.
How could it be otherwise except for
your course you say it cause in lobsters
and nature so that suggest it's even
more profound or the that the psyche is
deeper than just human,
right?
The psyche is all the universal
conscious and unconscious mind.
So I suppose what I suppose what I'm
thinking is how,
what my interest is is how can I,
let me ask you a question.
What do you think that you've done in
the last year?
That's good.
They are mostly small things.
Acts of kindness.
I have a daughter.
You have a good relationship with her so
that seems to be a good thing.
That's been beautiful.
That's been sort of in fact that is
hugely significant.
My new found ability to live at one
might refer to as an ordinary domestic
life.
My willingness to let go of other
people's perception of maybe things have
all been hugely significant and my sort
of,
I would say my dedication to sort of
self improvement in areas that could
still be regarded as selfish is one
thing.
Still an improvement to sort of take
exercise to look after myself.
I'm like drug and alcohol free for like
15 years and at this point that the
epiphany's are beginning to sort of
coalesce.
The things that that I feel I'm perhaps
most important is to let go of self
centeredness.
When I,
when I conduct myself in a,
when I'm not continually thinking what
can I get when I don't look at the
outside world as a resource when I don't
think,
what can that person give me?
What can they give me when I think he's
dead?
I have a chapter on that and 12 it's
called,
it says do what is meaningful,
not what is expedient and to do,
to view the world as a place of
resources that can be delivered to you.
It's in some sense to be expedient is to
take the short term,
it's to take the approach of short term
gratification,
something like that.
Yes.
Self centered is materialistic too.
It is materialistic but it's also,
it's also,
it's not optimal and it's,
it's not wise and the reason for that is
is that it actually turns out like if
we're going to have,
if we had a continuing relationship,
I would want to try to do a little bit
more for you than you do for me.
I could do that even purely selfishly
say because if I did a little bit more
for you than you did for me,
you would want to keep interacting with
me.
How does that,
all right,
so cause me and you I think get on
relatively easy.
We've found a frequency to communicate
on,
but say someone like the woman both high
in openness,
high in openness is a good service.
Now,
what about the woman on Channel Four
news who seemed more agitated and stuff
like do like me?
So we were actually having a
conversation,
we're trying to have a conversation
that's oriented towards discovering
something and you think she has a sort
of a series of linear bar model fruits
affects and she was just dropping them
regardless of what came back.
Definitely.
That's exactly what happened except once
there was once when you,
and you'll be mean to me and she was a
bit like founded.
Yeah.
Well when I complimented her on her
ability to really be an issue on the
spot when she said that she was the
wrong thing to do.
Yes,
yes.
Now the,
uh,
you are an academic,
clinical psychologist,
but in this moment,
do you not feel like it's a question
that could be,
you could easily post to me to feel
like,
I just want this,
like that's the person that's been in
front of you.
That's the world in that moment.
I don't think you have a particular
hospital to that person.
I'm messy,
but like,
uh,
do you not feel like in,
in that moment it w it would be of value
and of service to nurture that person?
Yes,
yes.
Well,
I had a conversation with a friend of
mine,
very smart friend of mine,
his name is Wayne Marecki.
Um,
he's quite,
he's quite the character wing,
but he w he watched and I've had people
watch what I've been doing for the last
18 months.
Lots of people.
And they report on what they think about
what I'm doing.
And so I asked Wayne about the interview
and um,
you know,
he was happy about the fact that I
conducted myself with a certain amount
of Carmen detachment and,
but he did say something very
interesting.
There was this,
there was the kind of,
the culmination of that interview was
where Kathy was challenging me about my
right to say things that might offend
someone.
And I said,
well,
I said,
essentially,
look,
you've based your whole career and this
interview on that.
Right.
You know,
and congratulations to you.
That's what you should be doing.
And then she was taken aback by that and
I said,
Gotcha.
And she,
she knows she was sort of flustered and
she said,
well yeah you did.
And Wayne said,
you know,
you could have instead of saying Gotcha
at that point you could have taken the
opportunity there to,
to expand on that opening and to try to
have Jason Conversation very north lane
for not doing that yet Christian thing.
Yeah.
Okay.
So I thought,
and I thought about that a lot.
I thought,
well that,
I think there were limitations in the
format.
Like by that time we were about 25
minutes into the interview,
you know,
so it was coming,
it was coming close to an end.
And you know,
sometimes being funny cause I think it
was reasonably funny.
It was reasonably witty sometimes.
That's okay too.
Well that's why comedians are useful
because they say funny things,
but this Justin,
yeah,
well hopefully they do and hopefully
they can get away with it.
Right.
And I think that that's often an
extremely effective conversational
maneuver
because he actually,
as a matter of fact you said so who
aren't coming to this.
Another thing,
I'm just frying a few things at you now
because you know the reason I do this,
cause I started doing a good degree at a
university of course,
so as called religion and global
politics and one of the main things they
taught taught me there,
or one of the things I've intrigued me
is the first thing they show you is this
bit of a bull shark.
There's bear literature by Boucher where
some story can't remember it called the
Chinese emperor system of taxonomy where
a show and the stories of the house.
I loved that game and I like,
and it's sort of an part of the courses
they took about who gets to determine
what words like natural or power.
I think,
you know,
who gets to determine how those terms
are allocated,
who gets to determine what's right
deemed
religious,
what's being rejected to build
[inaudible] because I wasn't going to
let the radical left just decided the
linguistic playing ground and that's,
they were trying to do you see their,
their rationale was we're on the side of
transgender people.
I said,
no you're not.
You're trying to control the linguistic
territory
in a sense like this is where this
conversation is a cure.
The parallels that conversation I had
with Sam Harris cause we have Sam
Harris.
What I found myself saying is why are
you so worried about this one particular
issue of zealousness or extremism when
it seems that power is actually situated
elsewhere.
It seems to me that,
you know,
I'm lost,
in that instance I suppose because that
was the incidence that came your way.
Uh,
you,
you as you told me at the radical left,
you know,
imposition of certain rules around
language that you have.
That was the reason for me plus the fact
that be split.
But you have also continued to Farro or
plow that far over.
Haven't you have considered tenue down
or sort of a line that seems like Telia
logically sensible with what happened
there?
Like is it continues to be,
he's like in a,
I know what you're saying.
Like I agreed with your analysis of the
word proverb provocateur.
If you don't,
you know there's a person is provoked if
they're not provoked,
you're not a provocateur.
So we say difficult labeled to apply to
anybody.
But it seems to me that you know when
some,
when people say,
you know,
young males are particularly sort of it
attracted to your work,
I do see that this is a time where males
need guidance and like where there isn't
the kind of elders,
our elders,
customs,
initiations,
routes to masculinity are in short
supply.
I can see that there's a real value in
that,
but I also feel that in this time of
social contention,
I then EU politics being part of it up
and conflict that will ideas that
promote unity and the emulation.
If those kinds of boundaries I feel to
me it would be particularly and
especially valuable.
Do you know,
again,
the right way to do that is to
concentrate on the individual.
And so,
so let me answer that two ways.
The first thing,
the first issue is that it isn't self
evident that the reason that my,
what I've been talking about has been
attractive to young men.
That might be uh,
uh,
like a fluke and it might be a fluke
because almost everybody who watches
youtube is male.
Yeah.
So like if I look at my youtube
audience,
it's 80% male,
but that's true of youtube audiences in
general.
So it's just a typical youtube audience.
Right.
And so what's his that you intuition
well,
cause I complicated
did not.
But I do know that since my book has
come out,
I've been watching the,
the demographics of my,
of my public audience that more and more
and more women are coming out.
So it's now to about 65,
35 from 80,
20,
and more and more older people are
coming out too.
So I think a fair bit of it was a
consequence of the fact that most of my
exposure and was to the youtube
audience,
which happens to be mostly men.
Now I do also think that there a
particular crisis with regards to what
might be described as proper pathways to
masculinity.
I also think that's at play.
So I think there's two factors.
But I also,
I don't think Kathy Newman kind of went
after me about this,
you know,
she said,
well,
you know,
if you're directing your message towards
young men,
which I wasn't assuming that's the case,
isn't that divisive?
And I would say,
well,
I don't think it is divisive because
first of all,
the masculine in women also needs to be
developed.
It's very,
very important.
And the people who are the enemies of
the masculine in men are also the
enemies of the masculine and women.
So if you overprotect your sons,
let's say you don't want to,
you don't want to,
you want to,
uh,
you,
you overprotect them in part and,
and,
and weaken them because you were afraid
of their masculine energy.
You're going to do exactly the same
thing to your daughters.
So that,
that,
so that,
that the evil is that female,
a female child would similarly be
disempowered?
Oh,
definitely.
Because you know,
the thing is,
this is another thing.
I am a psychometrician that's
technically my,
my job and we study may our measurement.
Well and like it's a truism of
psychometrics that men and women are
more the same than they are different.
You know,
it's funny because I've been sort of
positioned as someone who is constantly
on about the differences between men and
women,
but men and women are more the same than
they are different.
And what that means is that the
development of masculinity and women,
perhaps it's not as important as the
development of masculinity in men,
but it's damn important.
It's like it's a close second.
And so if people are pushing down
masculinity as a virtuous motive being,
then it's,
it has a detrimental effect on both.
Next Buddy.
I agree with this,
uh,
but I,
but you would say did the determinately
there and biologically that there is,
I think that his masculinity and that
thing,
masculinity is present in both females
and males.
Definitely.
Um,
but I,
I think again,
one of the,
one of the challenges that this argument
or the appears to be built around is a
sort of hierarchy around those traits.
Masculinity being synonymous.
For example,
with power.
Oh,
here's the thing.
I wanted to bloody ask him,
check this out.
Cause he was a bit,
I said it on a youtube video on my own
the other day and a four seat wonder if
they stand up to scrutiny.
That's,
give it a bit,
check this,
I sit like in Sweden,
they're banning sexually provocative
advertising and now it's a kind of thing
you hear a lot about like the
objectification of women.
And I said to go,
of course I support that because there's
a male being subjected to lots of
sexualized images of women has to a
degree affected,
uh,
you know,
particularly when I was younger,
my,
the logical conclusion to that is
pornography,
right?
Yes.
That doesn't really seem to be a good
thing.
It doesn't seem to be a good thing.
Yeah.
I don't look at pornography any more
light,
but pornography I think is,
yeah,
very corrupting,
corrosive influence for me personally.
It's not something I going to be
involved in.
I sit this check base.
Yup.
I goes,
um,
I feel the use of the female in
advertising a in general is the ease of
the perverted desire to worship the
feminine then negate it and neglected.
Feminine has found it's expression
through consumerism and commerce because
it is not being properly honored
socially.
What's your heart?
I made it up.
I would have to think that.
I'd have to think about that a little
time.
I would have to think about that a long
time because ideally it's,
it's an idea worth we're thinking about
for awhile,
like if there are essential,
if we have a central yearnings,
if we have like in like eeg,
if we,
if the in,
if in indigenous cultures we would have
diabetes to represent gender or certain
energies that are subtler than gender.
If there is a sense that socially those
energies are not being expressed on it
as you've implied with a male pathways,
that's definitely the case.
So one of the things that I've often
thought about etiologies is that
they're,
they're like parasites on religious
structures.
And if you're thinking that the,
the movement of feminine imagery up into
the consumerist world is an analog or is
at least in partial partial part,
a consequence of not having a symbolic
place where that attraction can be
expressed.
I think that's probably right.
It's like,
it's like in the United States is the,
the first family tends to be turned into
king and Queen.
Yeah.
Because there's no place for that
symbolic projection.
Yeah.
The template requires it.
I heard once an analysis of the Soviet
Union,
uh,
after the revolution that it mimicked
the monarchy tyranny that proceeded it
just in a different format and as
seeing,
yeah.
That so certain energies,
Holy Trinity even,
right?
Yes.
Mao,
Marx,
Lenin and Stalin depending on the
trinity.
And some would argue that we know sort
of like the Christianity couldn't take
hold in Latin America until they
embraced the Pantheism of the saints and
found and the figure of a virgin until
they like,
they know that in certain cultures the
the virgin had to be elevated because
there isn't a place in the father,
son,
Holy Ghost,
for the divine feminine.
You know,
that's a union idea.
Yeah,
yeah.
Oh yeah,
definitely that,
that's,
that's an original idea of yoga.
This is that cool that the trinity is
missing a core tile and sometimes that's
core tile is filled by the finger of the
devil,
and sometimes it's filled by the finger
of the woman.
So it's like,
it's like the houses in Harry Potter,
right.
There's three good houses and slitherin
is,
yeah,
there's in the bottom quadrant,
it's a,
it's a reflection of the same kind of
Mandela structure.
That's pretty cool.
It's very cool.
Very cool.
Have a place at the table for the
serpent.
You have to have a place that was in
sleeping beauty,
right.
In the Disney movie.
They don't let in that they don't crone.
That's right.
They don't invite her to the
Christening.
And so their daughter ends up
unconscious,
right?
They don't let the terrible mother come
to the party.
So how odder ends up unconsciously now.
Domestic normal,
everyday quotidian lives.
What is the parable mother?
How does that help section
overprotection
down?
I've ever protect the baby.
Late fall over a little bit.
That's right.
You do do the least amount possible for
your children.
It's something like that.
That's not neglect.
It's nothing like that.
It's like the old age home adage,
you know,
look,
I've seen this lots of times with
parents.
It's like maybe you have to get your kid
dressed up to go out.
Well,
it takes a long time.
If you let your kid do it,
you know,
it's a lot faster just to do it.
It's a lot faster not to have them set
the table.
It's a lot faster to do things for them.
Plus there's,
there's also,
and this is part of the devouring mother
archetype,
is like if you've devoted your life to a
child,
perhaps more than you should have,
let's say,
then it's very difficult to let the
child go.
What?
What's there left for you.
And so there's this terrible temptation
to play.
We'll all do everything for you,
but you never leave me.
And then for the child to say,
yeah,
that's right.
That's exactly the right face to make
for that.
That's a very terrible thing.
And you see that again in Disney
sleeping beauty where maleficent has the
heroic prints in the dungeon and it's
laughing at him,
right?
She's not gonna let them go until he is
ancient.
And that's,
and that's a consequence.
Can we see the devouring level?
We'll have some good pop cultural
examples of the Disney movies all the
time.
Um,
in,
in the little,
the Little Mermaid,
Ursula devouring mother,
the devouring mother shows up all the
time.
She's the witch.
She's the swamp dweller.
She's the,
she's the evil queen in Snow White was
the counterpoint.
The fairy godmother.
Fairy God mother.
Just one.
Yeah.
That's the positive feminine.
And that,
that happened,
that that archetype manifests itself all
over the place as well.
The,
the,
the fairy godmother's a good one.
Yeah.
And you'll see in,
in,
uh,
in sleeping beauty,
there's three of them.
Three little fairies that take care of
the princess and the forest.
They're there.
The archetype of the positive feminine,
so,
so you always see,
one of the things that distinguishes a
religious viewpoint from an ideological
viewpoint is that there's always a
representation of nature or the unknown.
Always you need one.
And if that's highly guys think
Christianity is the online,
well in Christianity,
I'd have to think about that for a
minute.
It partly,
it's the virgin mother.
It's mostly a positive representation in
Christianity,
so and that that would be the
representation of the benevolence of
nature.
It's something like that.
So that's the unknown.
But in a religious representation you
have the positive and the positive and
the negative aspect of the feminine.
That's also the unknown.
You have the positive and negative
aspect of the,
of the,
of the state.
That's the wise king and the d and the
devouring king,
and you have the positive and negative
representation of the individual and the
reason it's religious in some sense.
It's hard to explain why in a very short
period of time,
but a religious viewpoint always gives
you a balanced viewpoint.
That's what makes it religious.
It's like there's a positive element.
It's intensely positive,
but there's the negative counterpart and
there's a positive.
So let me give you an example here.
Um,
I can give you an example of how this
plays out.
Architecturally.
The frontier myth that settled the west
was essentially heroic,
individual positive,
bringing,
uh,
the benefits of ordering culture
positive to the desolate barren
wastelands of the west.
Okay.
So it's positive individual,
positive culture,
negative nature.
Okay.
So that's an ideology,
but it's a powerful story cause it's
true heroic individual bearer of
culture,
barren,
desolate wasteland.
It's true.
But one of the things that eventually
generated was a counter narrative.
And that because it was only half the
story,
that counter narrative was the
environmental narrative,
which was rapacious individual bringing
pillaging society into benevolent
nature.
And they had to recast the indigenous
people that lived on those land masses
is savage,
is not entitled to the same rights roic
individually.
There were actually two competing
tendencies in,
in the western mind.
One was the noble savage.
So that was the first son.
Exactly.
And the other was denison barbaric.
Dan is enough.
Yeah,
the uninhabited waistline.
So those are both arms.
The romantic idea of the noble savage
became some sort of whimsical new age
thing,
and they have a one and the other one
that Dennis in barbarian became
justification.
Vagina side.
All right.
Listen,
we look to wrap up because I can feel
the technological anx,
you know,
a variety of ways,
but a Dr.
Jordan Peterson or professor Jordan
Peterson,
I don't know why,
what,
how to big you up enough with the,
with your prologue.
Thank you.
Oh,
title.
Thank you very much.
I've really found it fascinating
conversation.
You have you enjoyed that conversation?
Yeah,
it's good.
I appreciate,
appreciated the invitation.